Our little program here is mostly funded by
viewers and listeners through the membership
program you can sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom,
Quick, Easy.
You get a daily extra show produced just for
our members and you can take advantage of
the coupon code.
Fresh start.
All one word, all lowercase fresh start saves
you hugely off of the cost of a new membership.
Apply the code fresh.
Start to the membership of your choice or
don't.
It's up to you at Join Pakman Dotcom.
Yesterday we briefly discussed this story
on the bonus show and in the hours following
the recording of yesterday's bonus show, the
story has exploded now with corroboration.
So let me kind of tell you what's going on
here.
And it is.
It's wild.
A staffer for Georgia's Secretary of state,
Brad Raffensperger, said yesterday that on
a phone call with Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham, Lindsey asked, could state officials
throw out some ballots to help Donald Trump
win the state of Georgia?
This is not an anonymous source.
This is election implementation manager Gabriel
Sterling, who has come forward and said, yeah,
I heard the same thing that Brad Raffensperger
heard.
So this is now corroboration.
The story, as we knew it yesterday morning
was that Georgia Secretary of State Brad Raffensperger
said, you know, I had a phone call with Lindsey
Graham and Lindsey Graham seemed to be implying,
let's see if you can throw out some ballots.
And he was referring, of course, to absentee
ballots, which skew heavily in favor of President
Joe Biden in the state of Georgia, as is the
case in many states.
So that was the initial claim from Brad Raffensperger.
Lindsey denied the claim, saying, it's ridiculous,
I didn't do it.
I wasn't trying to get ballots thrown out
or anything like it, even though Raffensperger
seemed very, very clear about what he heard
from Lindsey Graham, Lindsey Graham saying,
hey, you know, if there was political bias,
maybe poll workers accepted ballots that they
shouldn't have.
What if we find some ballots and we identify
some counties and we toss them out if we find
that there's a high rate of non matching signatures?
And Raffensperger reported being stunned that
Lindsey Graham was suggesting this and said
it sure seemed as though Lindsey Graham was
trying to go down that road.
So that was the initial claim and Lindsey
Graham denied it.
And then now, again, Gabriel Sterling has
said, I was on that phone call.
I heard the exact same thing from Lindsey
Graham.
So we found the attempted voter fraud.
Guys, the calls are coming from inside the
house.
It's Lindsey Graham saying, how about we tossed
some ballots in the trash?
Graham has said all along, oh, I was trying
to find out how does Georgia election law
work?
Does anybody believe that?
And Graham also, when asked about this, said
the president didn't urge me to do this.
Now, that's one of those meaningless political
statements that it could.
The letter of that could be true.
But in spirit, it might be a complete and
total lie.
When Lindsey Graham said, I mean, listen,
maybe Lindsey Graham came up with this idea
on his own, maybe Donald Trump came up with
the idea.
But Lindsey Graham might well be right by
the letter that Trump never heard.
Trump never called Lindsey and said, listen,
call Georgia, ask them to throw ballots in
the trash.
The way these things would work is that a
Trump staffer suggests to Lindsey Graham what
would happen if you were to get on the phone
with Brad Raffensperger and see what they
might be able to do.
This is like, you know, in Argentina and other
countries, my experiences with Argentina,
sometimes there are corrupt police in Argentina.
And, you know, you might get pulled over and
a police officer starts with, oh, you know,
not only were you speeding, but I think that
your brake light is messed up.
And I think that there's too much pollution
coming from your tailpipe.
I don't know.
I might have to get back up down here.
And, you know, and then you said the code.
You don't say, can I bribe you?
Right.
You say, wow, that's really inconvenient.
Is there some other way I might be able to
resolve this today?
Could we figure out a way to resolve this
right now?
And then this game is played of, well, what
did you have in mind or the right?
Right.
That's the way politics is done.
It's not Lindsey, it's Donald.
Tell them to throw ballots out.
So Lindsey saying he wasn't urged by Trump
is completely meaningless.
Now, is this illegal?
I actually don't know.
I mean, is the suggestion from Lindsey Graham,
if it were proven, is it against the law?
It sounds like it should be, but I really
don't know.
And you just.
Had to know that once Republicans started
screeching about voter fraud, it was them
who they were the ones who were going to try
to commit it, its projection.
And many people have written to me saying
David Brat Raffensperger is a Republican.
Why is he why is he going public and throwing
Lindsay Graham under the bus?
Yeah, Raffensperger is a Republican, but he
probably realizes there's really no way to
just throw out large batches of legal ballots.
Even if he had an idea of how he might be
able to throw out some batches of ballots,
Braford or probably realizes that the risks
dramatically outweigh the rewards, especially
since flipping Georgia, if he was able to
do it, wouldn't actually give Donald Trump
a presidential win in the Electoral College.
And in order for Raffensperger to get himself
out of possible trouble, maybe he's decided
to just go public and throw Lindsay Graham
under the bus.
Now, there's one other possibility.
Maybe Raffensperger is just acting with integrity
instead of hyper partizanship.
I'm so conditioned not to assume that that
I'm mentioning that second.
But it's conceivable that Raffensperger is
just acting with integrity here.
Now, one other thing.
We and others are calling this the real voter
fraud.
This really isn't voter fraud.
This is election fraud, which is the real
fraud we have to worry about.
Voter fraud is this retail strategy that Republicans
and Trump have been crying about, someone
trying to vote twice, someone showing up and
saying, I'm giving the name of a dead person
and casting a ballot or submitting a bunch
of fake absentee ballots.
That's really inefficient.
Those are stupid ways to try to steal an election.
What we're talking about here is election
fraud, which is abusing the law, trying to
do mass disenfranchisement of voters.
This includes stuff like using weak signature
laws to throw out votes from people with maybe
black sounding names or Hispanic sounding
names or whatever it may be, people from poor
areas intimidating people at the polls, doing
voter purges.
That's election fraud.
And that's really the concern.
And if this is true about Lindsey Graham,
what is being alleged?
It should be career ending.
It should be indictment garden garnering,
to be perfectly frank.
But nothing matters anymore to this party.
And more than likely, Lindsey Graham is going
to get away with this.
I hope I'm wrong, but I think he will get
away
with it.